hey das geht wir spielen jetzt ein
bisschen woanders wohnen
ich habe direkten gegner der super
erwischt
ich wollte ein bisschen rangers spielen
ohne wurst zu kaufen weil ich bin immer
noch ein vorproduzieren seht ihr
wahrscheinlich daran dass ich den selben
folian haben wie in den letzten game
wegen videos ich kann echt nicht suchen
ich weiß gar nicht wann ich das hier
gerade mache wenn ich das nicht kann
wahrscheinlich dass mich am besten töten
aber vielleicht versteckt ist ja
irgendwie zu suchen
auf jeden fall wäre schon fast null uhr
gerade und läuft hätte ich nicht
erwartet
und ich wollte gerade dieser dumme back
den habe ich völlig zurück zur lobby
freunde es ist dumm kommt klar timo ja
okay gut
das habe ich oft dass ich da irgendwie
drin stecke und dass sie irgendwas
drücke voll nervig okay ganz normales
kid wie es aussieht ohne irgendwelche
komischen heiltränke oder sonst was den
sinn kamen die rauchschaden machen wieso
kriege ich keine chance
gönnt er sich ein trank ich halt
irgendwie so gar keine schritte drei
jahre dauernder kampf aber wie gesagt
einfach so ein bisschen zocken und dabei
musik gehört dir habe ich direkt im
hintergrund die musik sollte ich glaube
ich lass mich killen hier keinen bock
auf dieses kunststück das nervt man kann
das auch irgendwie einstellen dass man
nur coole kids bekommen so was aber dass
wenn es zu stressig spiel einfach ich
wollte auch kein turnier machen sondern
ich würde genauso kämpfen einfach mit
hallo einfach mit ordentlich abwechslung
und dabei hintergrundmusik und ich bin
schon ziemlich milde freunde von display
könnt ihr mir hoffentlich nachsehen wenn
ich erstens im kampf ich schreibe
schreibe gar keinen gp entweder ganz
oder gar nicht welcher eigenschaft dass
ich
komplette mich kein verkauf zu gehen
jetzt super gefühl
ok jetzt werde ich glaube ich recht
rausnehmen jetzt dafür nehme ich mir die
zeit weil es noch keinen bock hat es
mich aber ich bin nicht gelegt kein bock
freuen kommt töte mich doch ich hab
möchte jetzt hier nicht ewig warten
tötest du mich jetzt mal dankeschön geht
doch vielen dank
sudeikis mega-event finde ich keinen
bock drauf hat zumindest ratings
verbieten geht egal automatisch spiel
trotzdem weiter ist zu kompliziert so
perfekt das sieht doch nach einem
anständigen kit aus irgendwie hat der pc
von meinem bruder ein bisschen von
meinem bruder gerade weil irgendwelche
komischen fehler dass man da die ganze
zeit die ränder sieht man diesen blöcken
aber das wird manchen unser problem
seien sondern sein problem sollte sein
des rechten daumens gefühl
das cool ich mag das irgendwie so auch
so aufzunehmen
aber mit musik und sowas moment direkt
redet das irgendwie so zu live-stream
feeling also wahrscheinlich wird ein
bisschen komisch sein zu als video
aber ich mache das gerne ist mir
aufgefallen dass ich das mal für psp
gemacht hat mein bruder oft an hängen
das macht ihr spaß warum tust du das nie
erwartet ein kanal teilst du mal wieder
irgendwann passieren sollte ist und es
nicht getan hast wer so rede ich mit
meinem zukünftigen ich wirklich so der
typ ist relativ kurzer folge geweckt zu
werden würde mir behaupten geschafft ich
bin irgendwie ich weiß nicht ich
schreibe ich dann habe ich habe auch
schon vollauf kommentar bekommt mehr
oder weniger zurecht finde ich so
schreibst du nur die g wenn du gewinnst
und das eishockey team dann bin ich so
euphorisiert und dann will ich direkt
freundlich sein und liebt seinen
schreibtisch wobei es hier eigentlich
eher ich finde dass das nette die ggg zu
schreiben wenn man selbst gewonnen hat
katar bisher weil dann heißt es hey was
du gott auch schiff 5 hertz hatte ja das
war peinlich
es darf nicht weiter passieren im sommer
die aufnahmezeit im auge behalten
sagen wir spielen so krupp zehn minuten
wieder das kit das mag ich
das klappte auch so er tritt nicht ein
bisschen viel
kann es sein das komplette der seine
lama habe ich echt oder habe ich nicht
ich wusste doch es hat er keine lager
mehr genervt weil mir die einfach mal
mitgenommen so frech wenig freunde ihm
einfach die lage von fremden leuten mit
von commander play genannt zu sein aber
nicht dieses coole play sondern leute
ich bin müde das merkt man glaube ich
ich glaube das video wird ich weiß nicht
wie das ankommen wird aber ich finde es
macht wirklich spaß gerade und das ist
ja das wichtigste ich dachte fall
schaden wäre aus von den in japan oder
ich hab in der wand gepackt das war auf
jeden fall geraten schande
ja ich meine kapuze auf als ging's da
kann man viel besser spielen musst du
dir das schon
ich wusste es auf jeden fall jetzt bin
ich ein gangster hatte mich eigentlich
gefallen
ich glaube nicht
ich bin auch 0 im pvp drinnen gerade
weil ich einfach letzten tage so viel
unterwegs ist nimmt man noch matsch oder
aufgehört geschafft
ok es fange ich noch an hier um zu
singen tut mir leid freunde stört könnt
ihr wegschalten fällt jetzt lustig
findet genug zuschauer sogar noch mal
rechtzeitig weil nicht mehr absicht mit
dem lgs zielgerade ein freund trifft
irgendwie so gar nicht der typ mir ein
bisschen leid alter was war das denn
okay es gibt gar keinen fall schaden
sogar sagen was war das für eine combo
aber es trotzdem weil es war echt toll
aber ich hatte eigentlich noch wasser
und so entsteht ich glaube nicht nennen
also klar wenn ihr ein und brennt dann
ist das das für unseren kollegen deshalb
ein system das den fall dass er ruhe
drin wenn wir uns selbst löschen können
tja freundchen
ok ja so kann es auch gehen freunde
machen drei münchen würde ich sagen okay
seine sache ziemlich lustig wenn ich
frage mich immer mehr leute sowas machen
machen die das etwa um keine ahnung dass
das leute das nicht nicht teilen und
dann irgendwie verlieren deshalb oder
warum macht lustig finden weil die üben
wollen sich schnell die rüstung
anzuziehen ist hat er mich besiegt aber
ganz oft haben wir auch leute
irgendwelche kids mit ihnen die dann
unfair gewinnen wollen und das finde ich
ja immer ein bisschen unnötig weiß
münster drauf saß protection ab es geht
ja niemals zu ende
das nicht dass man glaubt irgendwie zu
einem ende kommt mit dem schein wie geht
das noch mal der command okay ich glaube
länder war
damit geht oder ich bin ich halt einfach
so stand habe ich glaubst du länder war
der befehl und das sieht ja auch nach
einem guten letzten kitas freunde
78 das wo man und was mitmachen kann und
dann wenn ihr probieren damit zu machen
deswegen würde ich sagen ich zu
mitspielen oder bist du ja von
abschließend bewerten mehr lust einfach
zielscheibe zu sein alter irgendwie
fertig voll die combos von tablet pcs
schnecken erfolg das war nicht meine
absicht
er hat echt eine kette mit dem man ewig
lange kämpfen kann
das soll's recht sein wir müssen aber
probieren einigermaßen sparsam umzugehen
mit den ressourcen pfeiler hat man auch
jede menge eigentlich aber trotzdem
schauen wir mal die wörter dass wir
nicht allzu viele verbrauchen
okay ist eingeschlafen und ihren freund
dein extra herzen aber selbst bei
minimal zu tode
das könnte schon gleich die lager wieder
von ihm aber es machbar
der anfang war ein bisschen strange fand
im video
aber jetzt sind wir hier und wer noch
mit mir da ist das cool die anderen
nicht als jetzt hergeht aber ihr seid
nicht so gut wie die anderen aber wenn
ihr das video ganz halten schnauzte er
mit seinem feuer unmöglich finde ich das
jetzt bist du auch mal ein feuer und ist
hoffentlich gleich kein wasser mehr wird
ich würde sagen gespannt wer am ende
gewinnt zeit finde ich klasse
unberechenbar
jetzt hat er sein wenn ein heilkraut
oben
das habe ich glaube ich seine sache gut
da kann er mir da wird schon mal nicht
mehr auf die nerven gehen halte er
kriegt die übertriebenen combos sein
ja ja ja ich will hier auch technisch zu
schreiben kein tgo krass das warenlager
vermeldet ja ich hoffe es hat euch
gefallen das war's dann von heute war
wieder ein bisschen alternativ und da
würde ich sagen macht's gut und bis
dahin tschüss